fundamentally I don't think any
government policy is going to reverse
the fertility crash I'm completely
Doomer on that I think it's a spiritual
problem before it's an economic one but
I might be wrong let's give hungary's
Pro family policies a decade and see if
the cultural change beds in but even
Victor Orban who's been aggressively
pro-family and very expensively
pro-family in terms of that country's
policies it's seen some uptick in the
fertility rate but it's very small
fundamentally the issue is a spiritual
one it's cultural one I suppose the the
only the only sort of succinct
formulation I might want to give to that
is to say that technocapital is
structurally antenatalist and the only
way to fix the antenatalism thing would
probably be to smash techno capitalism
which is a fairly radical proposal and
it's certainly not one that any
political party is going to stand on in
next year's election